if there's a god how can he permit you
know that that the
it is the quintessential query right if
there's a god why does he permit evil to
happen that sort of thing
so a global pandemic you know over 500
000 deaths in america
yeah there can be well guess what every
single survey
including one i just read four days ago
the level of spiritual hunger has
increased exponentially now i'm not
saying it's for
organized religion i'm saying the level
of spiritual hunger
has increased exponentially so people
are hungry
for a relationship with god for greater
spirituality spiritual awakening
awareness so that's where we commit
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the president of the national christian
leadership conference
as well as the author of be light
reverend samuel rodriguez welcome to the
reuben report
thank you for having me i'm glad to have
you because you know there's obviously a
lot going on
in your world not only is uh just past
easter and the passover season uh but
obviously there's a ton going on on the
immigration front
and many of the things that i've been
seeing you talk about uh mostly on fox
lately are a lot of things that i talk
about on this show and
you made some sense on cable news that's
a pretty rare thing these days so
so i thought i could have you on for the
people that that don't know you can give
me a little bit about your
your back story first and then we'll
move into the current days
yeah i'm a kid from bethlehem
pennsylvania hence bethlehem i have a
messianic complex
uh my dad was a mack truck worker
my mom was a homemaker i graduated from
lehigh university
i was raised in an evangelical home my
parents are not preachers
i'm a faith and science guy ronald
reagan inspired the living daylights out
of me
and just prompted this commitment to
changing america and the world
with a value system that's
judeo-christian based
but this radical idea of god over man
and man over government
and so that's what we do my commitment
is to reconcile billy graham's message
of dr king's march i call it the lamb's
agenda it's doable
so you said a faith and science guy i
know my more skeptical
audience members their antennas just
went off what does a faith and science
guy mean
yeah i'm an evangelical trekkie so i'm a
faithful science guy i
i believe that that science is the
wonderful horizontal expression
of the reality of a living god uh
you know i i follow everything from
quantum physics my
my encounter with god at the highest
level took place in my undergraduate
studies at penn state university in a
quantum physics course
so i did not come through the normal uh
you know watching a television christian
broadcast
can you explain that a little further
that that's pretty interesting
yeah math and science it blew me away
the newtonian laws
uh leap cig uh the the ever increasing
reality of a universe that continues to
expand
the the beauty of the big bang uh the
intricacies
of the minerals that are out there in
the universe likewise
on this planet likewise in your
bloodstream and my bloodstream
the mathematical probability of that
happening by
chance it requires you to have more
faith
not to believe in a in a designer
and i'm sorry i don't have that crazy
cuckoo for coco puff
faith it does require you to have more
faith to believe this happened by chance
and just the math and the science all
adds up
um i'm a student of a guy named francis
collins
who oversees the the national health
institute right now and he has been for
a number of presidents for obama and
trump
um so again he discovered to a great
degree
unpacked unpacked better yet the human
genome
and he is a believer so again i don't
create a dichotomy between faith and
science
i think it's beautiful it's one
meta-narrative stream
that speaks to uh to a wonderful
architect
a designer a guy do you think that one
of our biggest problems discussing
this is that too many people do oh it's
it's just either or
you're either a believer in god or
you're a believer in science
these things can't touch right i
i that is a false dichotomy uh because i
am a believer in god i'm a believer in
science uh
absolutely and because i'm a believer in
science i'm a believer in god
it's one continual stream i think we
suffer from cognitive dissonance
like we're lacking the sort of cerebral
bandwidth and wifi
to really look at the big picture and if
we do
adhere to succumb to or acquiesce to the
idea
of a designer then everything else
becomes
a little bit more uh palpable
and if that designer has a plan for in
for the universe does he have a design
and a plan for individual lives
and then it becomes more personal and
that's where i come in as a pastor and a
preacher
and dissect that and bring it about
every single time so speaking of
your your job as a preacher in this last
year where we've had lockdowns and
pandemic and people out of work and all
of that stuff
have you noticed people looking for
something different spiritually or from
the church
you know what you would assume that a
global pandemic
would catapult the the quant the the
measurement or the metric of agnosticism
right from a logical continuum if
there's a god how can he permit you know
that that the
it is the quintessential query right if
there's a god why does he permit evil to
happen that sort of thing
so a global pandemic you know over 500
000 deaths in america
yeah there can be well guess what every
single survey
including one i just read four days ago
the level of spiritual hunger has
increased exponentially now i'm not
saying it's for
organized religion i'm saying the level
of spiritual hunger has
increased exponentially so people are
hungry
for a relationship with god for greater
spirituality spiritual awakening
awareness so that's what we commit and
that's why i fought back
when governor newsom in california in
our collective state you and i are part
of you are in california you are in
california yeah
i didn't want to i didn't want to help
you you outed yourself
you i had it myself when when he deemed
casinos and liquor stores essential but
churches and synagogues
not are you kidding me
you know guess who gets the call for for
health issues yeah we do
uh when young men and women right now
greater numbers in california as it
pertains to
god it's unfortunate the suicide rate
drug abuse
alcoholism depression we've never seen
these numbers guess who they call
they don't call a guy in the liquor
store they don't so jack daniels
you should not trump moses and jesus i
just it's just illogical
but that's what governor newsom did
while he was at you know having dinner
at the french laundry and that's
that's another story for him my audience
knows that story well
so fear not we don't have to dive too
much into that but you mentioned sort of
the role of god of government of of man
all of those things
you you've been able to piece something
together that that's pretty holistic
that sort of forms your
your political views as well it sounds
like
god over man man over government that's
the pecking order
that's american exceptionalism that
right there
god over man man over government and
when government grows
it's going to sound a little bit naive
or you know
here it is government grows it it pushes
man and god out of the way
this uber dependency on government and
this
unbelievable obsession with uncle sam
it's not part of the ethos of our
founding fathers it is
it's anti-american it really this
obsession with god
with government instead of instead of
our god ordained giftings and abilities
uncle sam is an uncle he'll never be our
heavenly father
he's just an uncle so we respect the
uncle
unless the uncle gets drunk in that
family party
you know we respect the uncle but we
worship god
and right now and even the recent
proposals from the biden administration
from the not just the 1.9 trillion but
now the infrastructure bill
all of this this unbridled growth
of government ladies and gentlemen uh
government is becoming our god i'm
pretty
i'm pretty sure and we are and we and we
are what we tolerate so we're tolerating
yeah and i'm pretty sure the
uncle is drunk at the moment he's drunk
and he's spending a lot of other
people's money
do you view that obsession with
government
as just the the next step down the road
because of the god-shaped hole that if
basically you don't you are not a
believer
you got to believe in something and then
government just kind of fills it in
do we find do we have measurable
elements that we can dissect
historically so it's not hype and it's
not rhetorical exuberance can we measure
it
let's measure it in it right after world
war ii 77 76
of all americans attended a church or a
synagogue 76
that number according to last week's
survey from gallup is now 48
for the first time what does this mean
let's not forget what we were fighting
back in the 40s and 50s communism
this idea of unbridled government being
gone
stemming out of the ussr through china
all around the world
here it is it's 2021 government is
growing
god god and meaning the belief in god
is decreasing in america it's directly
parallel
it's directly proportional the more we
get away from god
the more government plays a role in our
lives i'm telling you it's replacement
theology
it's not like we're doing away with god
and then there's this great vacuum
there is spiritual hunger and there's
hunger this is going to seem a little
bit
difficult for me as a with my worldview
this issue of dependency so who do we
depend on
god or government and we are replacing
god and
his abilities give things his his wisdom
uh his preordained institutions of
family
and so forth we're replacing that with
government
it's big government big government is
anti-christian
it's anti-jewish it's
anti-judeo-christian value system it's
anti-american
and right now we are drinking the
kool-aid all under the guise
of a pandemic if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell